bientôt on discute ici et bienvenue dans
ce prêche t otal l'épisode chacun des
quotas à quoi ressemble t par an on peut
voir des photos alors ma mère souhaite
garder son anonymat donc vous n'avez
probablement jamais un commentaire est
déjà apparue dans des vidéos que j'ai
fait il ya très longtemps et là même
film et même une vidéo dont voici un
court passage
c'était un court passage j'ai
l'impression que tu te dégarni tu
deviens n'est pas chaud non je vois pas
de quoi tu parles
avec quoi film 28 et vidéo il peux tu
nous l'a montré avec un miroir comme
cyprien
alors moi je filme des vidéos avec un
canon 600d et j'ai eu besoin d'un miroir
on vous la montrer as-tu déjà rencontré
d'autres youtuber bah oui bien sûr dans
sûr c'est évident salut les mecs ça va
ou quoi elle se mêle toi mon gars mais
si tu as 18 ans que en janvier que tu as
déjà le bac d'associer une classe alors
miel alors très bonne question
d'ailleurs on a posé cette question un
million de fois dans ma vie c'est juste
qu'en fait j'ai commencé l'école
maternelle un an plus tôt pourquoi quand
tu sourire ligotent et poussettes se
transforme en ring c'est pas ça va être
bien montre nous ton des tongs au chat
qui t'a dit j'avais un téton gauche mais
si tu étais une fille qui a sauvé ta
couleur préférée de 1 100 alors je pense
que si j'étais une fille ma couleur
préférée ça serait le 14 est mon chiffre
et nice seraient sûrement le rouge
et ceci n'a aucun sens bordel de merde
peut toucher ton coude avec talent
wahaha accepte d'après toi en train de
phacochères en régie du preneur et un
sanglier les petits que les ballets
n'ayant pas mangé depuis cinq jours et
13 heures lequel vu que qu'elle en
premier mais voyons tous oublié tes
petits clubs année il n'a pas mangé
depuis cinq jours si vous dire qu'il est
mort que l'on tient prête au combat et
tu donc personne ne sait comment fais-tu
des effets spéciaux alors j'ai acheté un
pack qui s'appelle actions essentielles
2a et en fait ça qu'on porte plainte
ce type d explosion de feux des morceaux
de verre qui est qui vole enfin des
trucs comme ça
voilà tout le monde s'en bat les
couilles depuis combien de temps tu as
twitter alors gelé sur twitter vous bien
après facebook parce que au début je
comprenais pas trop le délire
puis finalement j'ai fait le pas et je
me suis inscrit puis j'ai découvert un
peu comment ça marche est un peu comme
tout le monde et c'était il ya environ
je pense un angle il est d'ailleurs je
vous invite à me suivre sur twitter
parce que je lui dis des conneries ou
des photos de m voilà c'est @ x quizy
très bien comment mais tu tes
chaussettes aux chaussettes de croquer
la halle et je n'ai pas mes chaussettes
c'est elle qui viennent à moi
avant sa guitare 1 2 3 et 4
voilà c'est ce que j'ai appris à faire
de plus par rapport à avant c'est à dire
par rapport à ça c'est pas mal c'est un
bon demis trop quel jeu a marqué ton
enfance - le jeu auquel j'ai joué à mort
rester petit pont du coude sur ps1 avec
mon frère mon geek est vraiment
énormément sur ce jeu et c'était plein
de bons souvenirs et on l'a observé
crash bandicoot le jeu auquel je jouais
quand j'étais petit tu te laves en
caleçon je pensais pas être quelqu'un de
questions mais en fait oui des gens
fiables ce qui est la source
c'est quand tu t'appliques du cerveau et
protégerait faut je pars pas avec lui je
crois que c'est l'une des p o c'est un
choix il faudrait